ما في شي ابن الاجواد ما في شي ابن
الاجواد ما في شي ابن الاجواد يا عس عروس
الكب داعس عروس الكلاب وداعس عروس الاوغاد
داعس عروس الاوغاد وداعس عروس الاوغاد
داعس عروس الاوغاد وحط السيف قبال السيف
حط السيف قبال السيف وحط السيف قبال السيف
حط السيف قبال السيف واحنا رجال محمد طيف
واحنا رجال محمد طيف واحنا رجال محمد طيف
واحنا رجال محمد طيف يا ابو خالد لا تهتم
يا ابو خالد لا تهتم بنهان ابنك حر وما
بنهان وابنك حر وما بنهان ابنك حر وما
بنهان ويا قواسم استنى استنى يا قواسم
استنى استنى ويا قافيش استنى استنى ويا
قافيش استنى استنى واحنا زيك بدنا الجنه
واحنا زيك بدنا الجنه واحنا زيك بدنا
الجنه واحنا زيك بدنا الجنه يا خليل
الرحمن يا خليل الرحمن وابنك باطل ما
ينهان ابنك
بطل